I,
you may,
you may recall of that,
uh,
last time we went over the shape of a dentist,
Cosmo's remember the,
and the point there,
one of the points,
uh,
was to show that the context of Dante's experience,
the way he moves the tail,
he's telling about this extraordinary experience he has.
It's really the whole cosmos.
It's not,
it's not just,
uh,
one's whole,
our town one's own place and so on.
It,
it really,
it really takes place within the cosmos.
And we saw her,
Dante describes that cosmo was,
uh,
he describes it in terms of a physical in the metaphysical or principles as,
hey,
here's all the materiality and the spirituality of two hemispheres.
All placed in one and a.
The imperian,
Eh,
is the,
the threshold and the limit of the physical cosmos and the way of entering into
the spiritual cosmos.
Uh,
the challenge he has as a port is that to show the relationship between the
finite and the infinite,
the way that they are really disjointed.
At the same time,
they are note the finite universe can only be part of the infinite universe.
And so he describes how the infinity enters the finite and the finite and the
infinite.
This is the heart of the Cantos of metaphysics,
which we'll call that,
which we can call that cancers of physics and metaphysics at the same time.
Now,
Dante moves straight into the Imperian.
He was in the Er.
You remember into the [inaudible] or the crystal lean heaven.
Before that,
there wasn't the heaven of the fixed stars.
25,
26,
37.
Then he moved into the,
uh,
the,
the crystal lean.
Now he's,
uh,
into the,
Imperian uh,
this is the end of,
uh,
of,
of the race for him.
It's the end of the journey.
Uh,
the question will be,
uh,
how he is going to say farewell to Beatrice.
There'd be a change of the guard.
Uh,
Beatrice,
the role of Beatrice as a guide.
We'll stop.
We'll end with Canto 30 of paradise.
Quite appropriately.
It's suitable.
She's the woman tied with the number 30.
She appeared in Canto 30 of predatorial,
uh,
stays on the stage of the poem for 33 Cantos and now she's going to actually
disappear.
He realized that she has disappeared in Canto 31,
but there's a change of the guard because Dante moves from Beatrice to Eh,
uh,
contemplative,
a historical figure,
a or all the time or almost all the time with Dante.
Um,
Bernard of Clairvaux who was a famous monk of a French monk who,
uh,
stands for,
tr is written treatises on contemplation and mystical vision.
So appropriately he's the one who will usher and pray the Virgin Mary that she
may in turn pray her son.
It's a chain of mediations so that the beatific vision may be granted to Dante.
That's going to happen.
We can't have 33 and we're going to find out the difficulties that Dante has a
both scene,
but above all in recalling,
in recollecting the poem will end up with,
uh,
being assaulted.
Uh,
registering the feet are the unavoidable refit of memory and the importance of
forgetfulness.
So we're going to find in Canto 33,
it's sort of a,
a further twist to the metaphor of you remember incantatory three or pull that
order that I mentioned to you where it was happening.
Dante will go on being immersed ritually into the river Liffey and then into the
river.
You know,
the two rivers one,
the river of forgetfulness,
the one the river of memory of good memory.
And 90 goes on saying that they really came the,
he was at the point where the,
the two streams where really are originating from the same source.
It is as if memory and forgetfulness,
first of all,
are equated with water.
They're in Canto 33 of purgatorial implying Dell ability.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the water has that quality of flowing,
the fluidity,
the ability of both member and forgetfulness.
But it was important thing is that they originated from the same place.
It is as if Dante,
we're really preparing what,
what we'll move now front stage in po but at least or 33,
namely the notion of a forgetful memory and the importance of forgetful memory.
You have to forget and you have to remember and somehow they too are going to,
to be brought together.
It's not a mystical proposition that he advances.
It's actually the,
uh,
the way of justifying his poem.
And we'll come to that in some detail.
I hope in,
uh,
when we come to Canton 33,
what I would,
uh,
emphasize or to move now to cancer surgery,
Dante's entering into the heavenly Jerusalem,
uh,
which is a garden in the facility.
Uh,
and we'll be described as such.
you,
you will see in,
um,
well let's turn right now to this images.
Uh,
oh,
this is really cancer 30 line,
a sequence of images aligned.
Uh,
uh,
32,
I'm sorry,
110.
And following page four,
three,
seven,
I saw a and 12 line,
112,
I saw,
um,
rising above the light hole around the more than a thousand tears as a many of
us have returned there above the heavenly Jerusalem is first of all,
describe as a theater.
And we ought to really think about it for a moment.
The theater and if the lowest rank,
that's the images of the theater,
uh,
where you have in an auditorium today,
tears,
uh,
and closest with it.
It's so great.
The light.
Why is the expense of this rose in?
It's what is the expense of this rose in the pharmacy pedals.
The second image is that it's described to describe this,
uh,
the heavenly Jerusalem is the Rose White rose and mystical rose.
And that can tell you immediate,
this instant is using,
using the image that this is,
uh,
it derives straight out of a a 13th century French poem called the Romance of
the Rose,
uh,
with which Dante had translated.
There's a young man into a sequence of Saunas,
part of his experimenting with Poetic Forms,
but it's also,
it's deeply altered because the romance of the Rose,
which is an extraordinary satirical poem,
uh,
tying to a compendium of all knowledge.
It really has,
it's,
it deals with,
it's a story of about nature and about the reason the connections which were
written regional in nature,
but it's also a story with asexual.
Uh,
FIM.
Dante is clearly taking that language of the romance of the rose and literally
spiritualizing reversing it.
But uh,
the resonances of the original poem are still there so that you are forced to
think of,
uh,
of the heavenly Jerusalem is also having some kind of materiality,
a within it.
You can not just say,
well,
I'm taking that image,
place it in a different context and hope that the original,
the residues,
the traces of the original image are going to be completely phased.
It's part of the strategy of once again hinting,
intimating that spirituality and materiality now are still going to be a
converging here.
So that's the archeology,
let's say,
of this image of the rose.
So a discontinuous line,
next paragraph into the yellow of the terminal rose,
which expands,
arises in ranks and the sales orders of praise to the sun that makes perpetual
spring.
Beatrice drew me as one.
We silent and Fein would speak and she said,
behold,
how great is the assembly of the white robes?
He says,
a procession,
a theatrical performance of souls.
The whole of paradise is a theatrical performance and whatever we think of
theater.
Now let me just reflect a little bit on this image where we think of a theater.
We understand that it implies the reduction of the world to a spectacle.
That's where the theater is.
The world is something to be seen.
It's also an optical phenomenon or a case to put it in another way,
which really does not do any violence on the other text.
A question of the representation.
The world is at a presentation implying that I become the spectator.
I am.
It's their representation for me.
I can really watch this world and see it in its whole totality,
just as Dante seat the whole of the universe.
And now he can see the whole totality of the blessed.
This is the whole of the heavenly Jerusalem where all the blessed who will be
sitting,
enjoying acting and spectating,
uh,
at the same time.
So two,
three things that I want to say here.
On the one hand,
the theater is an image of multiple perspectives,
right?
That's where the theater,
that implies you are sitting there and I'm standing here,
um,
multiple perspectives,
but Dante wants to say that he's enjoying an overall perspective of what we call
a perspective of the whole.
He can see the whole of reality.
He sees the whole expanse of the horizon of the world.
So in other words,
whatever he's saying about himself,
it partakes of and it belongs to the totality of the world.
He's not seeing something isolated or disconnected with the rest of the world.
This is to him what legitimizes a claim to be a visionary poet.
To be truly a visual report,
you have to be able to see the whole of reality,
not just like in her sisters,
your own image,
not like someone who is bound to one's own perspective.
Once home self,
he sees the whore of the world.
And that's really what I think is the claim or the implications are of the image
of the theater.
The first,
uh,
I think that the need some glossing,
behold how great is the assembly of the white robe.
Okay.
Um,
sense of the magnitude of the spectacle.
Then see our city,
how great it is.
It's circuit.
It has been described a little earlier,
eh?
So in terms of a rose and the garden and now it's a city,
that's an interesting shift in Dante's poem.
It's an interesting shift for a number of reasons because the whole poem now
appears as literally a journey from the wilderness,
not to the garden,
but to city of,
to a garden,
which is a city.
It is a way of encompassing the whole movement of the poem within this two
figures.
This is it,
this as if the whole impulse behind this,
this experience of Dante is a reintegration into what is,
it implies the place where many of the people are as if we're only seeing the
world as a whole.
I want to be part of this hall.
And the way of being part of this whole is this political polling,
this city,
uh,
heavily set it to be sure,
but it's,
it has,
uh,
the,
the idea of city always implies some human compact,
some human,
uh,
idea of,
of,
uh,
what do we call usually that Paul is the political,
political reality.
Let me just add something else,
which is interesting.
In terms of Dante's imagination.
We have a compression of images from the pastoral tradition,
the garden,
and the idea of city.
And we do know that when you read pastoral literature,
you really have usually have this juxtaposition.
It's called between the herbs,
which you know,
is the,
uh,
the terms or the urban.
Now they are the city,
uh,
from the,
from the reus,
the Rustic,
uh,
a division between gardens and cities.
Uh,
this is the economy on which pastoral literature,
eight logs you call colleagues ideals.
Idyllic literature is usually based on,
on this divergence between the two modes of the imagination.
Uh,
I live in the city and then I want to go down into the villa.
I want to go down to the country.
And as if they were to a kind of a,
almost a hint of a schizophrenia existence that you have with a Roman.
And,
and,
and in Greek poetry,
Dante's doing is literally shattering that distance between the two modes in an
eschatological perspective and the perspective which is at the end city and
garden come together.
It is literally a change both in the idea of the city and in the idea of the
garden.
There are no two divergent modes of the imagination.
They're really cool here within one.
You see what the point is?
The point is that no matter what Dante is touching with his imagination,
all the opposition's,
all systems of contraries of contrary forms,
he tries to always bring them together in a kind of concordance.
Discordance made come cold and again,
which is the idea of music.
It kind of harmonization of all this,
uh,
this oppositions in everything that he has,
we so far have been seeing.
But now that it's a further image,
which is sort of complicates the problem was see our seats so failed that few
souls are not wanting there.
This is a kind of line which is really strange because it's implying that uh,
for all us,
all of us late comers,
there's no room,
there's not even standing room there for us.
So as the,
the,
the places have all been taken,
almost all being taken,
very few implication here are going to be saved,
but then one can make this claim.
It follows because he really believes that this is a kind of,
uh,
that he,
he,
he has had and what we call it,
an apocalyptic vision that the end of the world is near.
Therefore,
he can say only a few seats are available or,
which is really the way I think that because I don't think that [inaudible] has
an apocalyptic vision or this was,
hey,
what I mean by apocalyptic vision,
apocalypse means visionary.
He's a visionary.
Apocalyptic means implies the imminence of the ending of history.
I don't think that he has that idea.
I call it man who keeps thinking as he does about the renewal or the corruption
of institutions.
They hope that some intervention will come from other human beings or of history
king for instance,
or a,
an intervention from the world of grace and not really have a sense of the
imminence,
consummation of history.
You see what I mean?
You wouldn't be worried so much about renewing the institutions.
What are then the line then this line is to can be taken from it and that thing
has to be taken to me.
Is that seen from the perspective of eternity as he is really there are a few
seats.
You see what I'm saying?
That if you see it in terms of uh,
the totality of,
of time,
then they are not a lot of time has been,
has,
has already passed by and then he will continue a haunting image.
I think that sort of gives all this talk of this much reflection from city,
uh,
whether Dante's or has an apocalyptic imagination or northern apocalyptic
imagination.
Uh,
look at this,
how this absence and the in that gray chair on which that I sort of held by the
crown there is already set over it.
An MTC,
it's taken.
A crown is on it.
A King is going to be selling.
That's what I call it,
haunting image of Rodeo,
our royal absence and royal presence because it's,
you'll see it in a moment what it is
before the shelfs or supper.
This nuptials charrettes,
the soul which shall be imperial below of Lofty Harry.
This is the emperor,
uh,
who actually died in 13,
13,
whom Dante was hoping would come down to easily from the holy Roman emperor come
down to Italy to set the eatery straight.
There is to say to plicate the violence between the cities,
the,
the whole history of Italian communes,
but he had died prematurely and he's expected in heaven.
But you see,
so there is a way in which they've,
the king,
the emperor is beatified.
His seed in heaven is to be assured and yet implying that somehow their violence
in history is going to be for the time being continued and prolonged.
So a political,
a political interests that political,
uh,
the,
the keeping the holding on to dentist own,
uh,
fantasies or political renewals that gives their,
for the salt of the tempers or views that Dante may have,
an apocalyptic imagination that brine greed,
that big witch's you has made you like the infant,
etc. It,
uh,
and then Dante goes on.
Uh,
the other great problem that Canto ends with a final denunciation about Simon
Margolis and the reference to him.
Fair 19.
This is the high to the university.
Can Forget Simon Margot's can in federal,
in team and Bonnie for us the eighth,
uh,
gets his juice and shall make him of our nine year go pop a if as the A's go
deeper still,
you remember how they were,
they were punished being upside down in the ditches and the flames of fire,
Pentecostal flames of fire on the soles of their feet.
This is the way they had been twisting around,
turning around the gift of prophecy.
Okay,
let me just go on to Ken to 31.
Um,
it's really a farewell to Beatrice and I thought that we were expected so much
for arrival in Canto 30 of Purgatorio.
We should see how,
uh,
the farewell,
takes place.
Uh,
uh,
and so,
let's turn 10 to 31 lines 40.
And uh,
following page four 49,
I who had come to the divine from the human.
This is Dante speaking for himself to the terminal from time and from Florence
to people just insane with what I'm [inaudible] must have been filled truly
between that and the joy was contend to hear nothing and to remain silent.
And like a pilgrim who is refreshed in the temple of his vow is he looks around
and hope sometime to tell it again.
So taking my way up through the living light,
I carried my eyes through the ranks.
Now up now down,
he looks around to see who,
whom he sees and he actually would go on listing the number of,
uh,
blessed women and men that he sees.
Um,
I killed my eyes to the wrench now up and down and they're looking around again.
I saw faces persuasive to charity,
uh,
used to chat it adorned with another's light and with,
they're all smiles so that this blessed are blessed because they are,
there's some,
some other in them,
they are themselves and that is an other in them tool.
And we'll own smiles.
And every movement graced with dignity.
Already my glands had taken in the whole general,
um,
taking me the whole general form of paradise,
what I,
what I called earlier,
the vision of the whole,
the totality that he manages to gazes said,
but had not yet well on any part of it.
And that turned with new kindle eagerness to question my lady of things in which
my mind was in suspense.
We have now eh,
um,
re vision,
Eh,
rehashing if you wish of the scene of Virgil's disappearance when Beatrice is
just about to calm Dante.
So all stricken by and,
and,
and sees by tremor at the approaching of Beatrice that he turns around to try to
see and get comfort from Virgil and Virgil had vanished,
who have now a kind of variant of that say,
Ma Vanishing Act.
One thing I intended and another encountered me,
I thought to see Beatrice and I saw an old man,
Bernard of Clairvaux,
the great enemy of,
uh,
um,
the so called of the philosophers,
but I don't want to get into that.
Clue did like that glorious company.
His eyes and his cheeks were suffused with a gracious gladness and his aspect
was of such kindness as befits a tender father and where is she?
I said,
in haste,
and he replied to end thy longing beauty sent me from my place and if they'll
look up to the third circle from the highest tier,
Tasha,
see her again in the throne.
Her merits have assigned a ha without answering.
I lifted my eyes and saw her when she made for herself a crown reflecting from
her the eternal beams from the highest region with thunder snow mortalized so
far where it lost in the depth of the seas was my site they have from Beatrice,
but to me it made no difference for her.
Image came down to me and limbed by art between Oh lady,
here he goes,
oh,
now and who my hope has its strength and who does bear for my salvation to leave
their footprints in hell?
Of all the things that I've seen acknowledged that grace and the virtual to
brief from that power and from like goodness,
it is now,
who has drawn me from bondage into liberty.
The great theme of Liberty that we have been discussing,
uh,
especially in purgatory.
Uh,
fancy.
Also,
it's,
it's sealed here in the presence of Beatrice,
uh,
et cetera.
Uh,
so this is a,
now he turns to the Faithful,
uh,
Bernard,
you better remember that 10 to 29 ended with,
uh,
Beatrice very worried that Dante has been expounding.
You Remember Canto 28,
29,
they'd been the exposition about angels,
the exposition about creation,
creation as an act of God's love,
um,
the,
the ordering and the new ranks of a,
of,
of angelic [inaudible] angelic choir.
And then,
uh,
Beatrice gets very upset because,
the,
the holy shoe seemed to be to her way of thinking more about the appearance of
things rather than the truths of saints.
You remember that,
uh,
she attacks as human beings on earth.
They do,
they do nothing else then go after false appearances.
We are swayed by false appearances.
So that the question was,
what does she mean that the truth is she was saying,
let's get back to some,
let's bring,
bring,
bring some kind of sense of the real back into play.
In all of this sense of the,
of,
of the truth value,
what we are saying back into this representation.
Uh,
and that was the way it was.
The weekend or 29 stopped with Beatrice suspicious of appearances.
Dante now gets into Canto 30 and 31 and goes back to the passion of appearances
and says that to Beatrice that the appearance is exactly what the image is
exactly what he has preserved is going to preserve of two things and what they
have to be follow from this.
Are you with me in all of this,
uh,
issue,
Dante saying here in the encounter with Beatrice,
uh,
the highest with our answer or lift up my eyes.
And so how will she made herself a crown reflecting from her the turn beam.
This is the language of emerge in the language of reflections.
What Dante is saying to Beatrice is that we are always in a world of images and
that somehow the images,
the images,
the locals of the sacredness,
but the images also has its own fleet in quality.
And the journey of Dante's to go between the images and the essences.
Now he's preparing for the final leap.
This is to say that none of this journey was not a journey to be addressed.
It's going to be a journey to God.
Beatrice is a stepping stone for the pilgrims,
uh,
entering the experience of the beatific vision.
So this is what I want to,
uh,
to emphasize.
And in fact,
Ken two three one ends with like one that comes line one on 13th,
like one that comes perhaps from Croatia to see our Veronica Veronica is an
illusion to one of the pious women who during the calvary ascent of Jesus,
he said to have wiped his face.
And the face of Jesus remained imprinted on her veil.
And so that Veronika became,
uh,
the,
it's the name of the woman Veronica,
but it was sort of understood in the hollow middle ages as Vera it Kona.
This was the kind of phony to be sure etymology given to the Veronica.
It was Dante's evoking.
Now the pilgrims who come to,
who got to Rome from Croatia to see the true image left imprinted on the veil of
the Veronica.
This is where Dante himself.
Yes,
he is like one of those pilgrims who still seeing the image but wants to move
beyond images,
wants to go and see what lies behind it.
The journey of the divine comedy is the journey within that interstice between
images and essences.
Uh,
so to speak.
This is Veronica and we're old.
Hunger is never satisfied,
but he says with himself,
as long as this shown my Lord Jesus Christ,
very guard was this then your true semblance.
Such was eye gazing on the living charity of him.
Who in this world tasted by contemplation of the piece.
So,
uh,
that's how we can,
we are ready to get into Canto 33,
uh,
which is the final canto and the final vision.
Let's see how Dante carries that off.
And uh,
uh,
let me begin with,
um,
with uh,
uh,
saying a couple of things that are,
there are a number of dramas that will go or are going to be unfolding in Canton
33.
The first drama is that of a pilgrim who wants to see the face of God,
wants to see the face of God,
wants to preserve the width so that he can be come back and be a,
can be able to come back and re retail the story,
tell the story,
write the poem as a witnessing to the vision,
his head.
So it's a,
it's a way of thinking about the relationship between vision and language.
If you want to say it in a very general way are how are the two related to each
other?
But the real,
the other drama is how is he going to remember,
can he remember in number four,
what does he really see?
These are the,
the number of,
uh,
problems that he faces.
The poem begins with the,
the Canto 33 begins with a prayer,
a prayer to the Virgin,
a Virgin Mary or the virgin mother.
Uh,
and it's,
it's going to be constructed through a series of paradoxes.
As you can see,
virgin mother,
ah,
paradoxes,
daughter over your son paradox about time,
pedagogues,
about all sorts of reversals of the natural,
older,
a lowly and exalted more than any creature and where you're off of using
paradoxes that challenge the rational understanding of the world.
This is not going to be irrational representation of a,
of what Dante was.
See fixed goal of the turtle counsel.
You are,
she who did so unknowable human nature that it's maker did not disdain to be
made.
It's making in your womb.
So Dante goes on now to that Motif of birth with which we began talking from in
fair,
no one when we discussed the Virgil,
this idea of uh,
the,
the beginning,
the idea of a beginning of birth.
It's an image of beginning and an image of a,
um,
nature becoming an event.
The idea of nature becoming a historical event.
The possibility of it is historical event nay,
um,
in thy wound was rekindled the love,
but who's warmth?
This flower,
the flower.
This flower really means the whole of the mystical rose that he has just seen.
So the mystical rose begins in,
it's contained in the womb of Mary has broom that's in the eternal peace.
Um,
it's another way of,
uh,
of,
of making this,
uh,
this idea of I could close this image of the womb as,
in terms of this is the men's sphere of the mistakes.
Yeah.
Within which,
you know,
the men's field within which,
uh,
the finite and infinite come together and meet the immense fear.
It's a circle,
the immense via whose,
whose,
whose center is nowhere,
uh,
or whose center is everywhere,
whose circumference is nowhere.
That's the way he's understanding.
And he's explaining,
uh,
this motif of the,
the,
the incarnation and what is crucial about this image.
I believe it's first of all,
the humanization of the divine cannot.
This is clearly,
uh,
the divine that becomes divine because it enters history and experiences all
that,
the human being's experience.
The other element that I think that Dante is pushing forth is the feminization
of the divine in the sense that here,
uh,
the divine has become the child of a woman and the woman is therefore part a
taste subsumed as part of this divine,
a kind of feminine.
Uh,
I don't call it is,
I don't really know what that is,
but the feminine and that'll mean that this,
uh,
in,
it's,
it's a true statement.
I don't know.
Uh,
but it's a feminine,
a theology of Feminine Element in God.
Uh,
so here that water to the moon,
they torch of charity and below I'm a maltose or living spring of hope.
And then the second,
uh,
stylistic theme here is the repetition,
the iterative mode.
Thou lady here skip a few lines and thy loving kindness in his mercy,
in the PT,
in the great bounty in the is joined or goodness,
they're in a recruiter.
What is the point of this iterativeness of the style of reputations,
of Anna Forex style?
I think one of the reasons you may think of others,
but one of the reasons is a language that is falling upon itself as a way of
giving consistency to itself.
The appointment is tied at this point is really dealing with a vanishing
tracers.
I think that not quite be pinpointed or placed within logical propositions.
And therefore the language becomes incantatory as if it were an effort to create
a kind of a mood,
sort of a creating a reality through this,
uh,
this mood and do through these iterations.
And then the prayer of Bernard continues this man and in the pilgrim line 30,
20,
this man who from the northernmost pit of the universe to here has seen one by
one the lives of the spirits in our bags of the but I grace for such power that
with his eyes he may rise still higher towards the reservation.
And I,
this is extraordinary.
We are in a paradise
so far.
Not to stray so far from the temptations of mystical writing,
which ends up is evoking identities are represented on representable identities.
Dante distinguishes very carefully to till the end with an eye and he,
ah,
there are individualities in this paradise of Dante's imagination and die.
This is Bernard who never burned from my own vision more than I do for his see
the differences.
I and him are offered to the all my prayers and pray that their capital short,
that polite prayers that will disperse for him every cloud of his mortality.
So the supreme joy may be disclosed to him.
That's the first prayer to the virgin.
This I prayed to the queen who can stick with our will that they'll keep his
affections pure after.
So greater vision.
So the first danger to the pilgrim is that he may be losing literally his mind.
Uh,
the vision of God.
May it face my obliterate his powers of this vision [inaudible] the powers and
the affections,
let that guardianship control his human impulses.
See Beatrice and so many of the blessed who clasp their hands for my prayer is
an extraordinary vision.
The whole of the cosmos is pray for the beauty.
Dan,
the pilgrims,
beatific vision,
the eyes by God beloved and real and die.
This is who was drawing near to the end of all desires.
I am.
I want to emphasize this,
even this language of desire up to now,
the poem has been,
can be called literally,
we could have been calling it so many things,
pulling of hope,
a poem of peace.
It's a poem of exile,
a poem of desire,
Paul of longing.
And the prayer is the mode of this longing prayer.
You,
you address,
someone you don't see,
hoping that you can be heard and that that your prayers can be answered.
There's a desire for a response.
This is really the mode of Dante's theology.
Uh,
at the heart of his theological universe.
There is a sense of constant longing in the sense of being not quite where he
wants to be.
Um,
and that who was drawing near to the end of our desires.
I emphasize in that prepare you in case I will not make a point about that very
soon,
the language of Dante will change from desire to enjoyment.
He starts getting the sense of the sweetness and this idea of the fullness of,
uh,
of his,
his,
his pleasures are desire we'll shift into,
into joy very soon,
uh,
ended before.
So the order of my craving,
Bernard signed to me with a smile to look upward,
but radio of myself,
I was doing what he wished for my site becoming pure was entering more and more
through the beam of the lofty light,
which in itself is true.
And now the first defeat,
Dante starts recording,
um,
the forgetfulness of the experience.
From that moment,
first of all,
my vision was greater than a speech with fails.
It's such a site.
How are you going to make a failure become a success?
How from the fact that he is not going to be able to see will become somehow a
mode of his own,
not just the humility,
because it would be a success in terms of the pilgrims on humility.
But in terms of the writing of the poem and the right of the poem will be,
there will be a different way of understanding the problem.
You're not just wanting to be a representation of where plenitude of vision,
but till the end,
the statement of a longing for a vision that may come and the memory to fails
has such access.
Access in Italian is really the language.
I don't know the probably the English is best etymologically it's the same
thing,
but in Italian is the outrage,
outrage,
the sense in which,
uh,
with,
with the restaurants that that is something,
uh,
two bold,
so an over a kind of hyperbolic and overreaching or is that's really what it is.
An access as an overreaching like him that season a dream and after the dream
that passion wrote by remains and the rest returns not to his mind,
such a [inaudible] from a vision almost wholly,
almost,
almost wholly fades and still their drops within my heart.
The sweetness that was born from it,
that's all he's going to be left with the sweetness that gathers in the chamber
of the heart.
This has been a journey of the heart.
It is because as I've been saying to you in a number of ways,
in that in the past few weeks is the,
the,
the journey to God is a journey of the mind,
but it's a journey of the heart.
You have to,
you will come to know God through this idea of the heart.
But also,
you know,
that is really punning on the notion of what memory is.
Because to him,
memory is connected also with the hearth.
What can I remember?
What can I record within me?
Ah,
what is this,
this uh,
uh,
and the only thing that memory can,
can,
can retrieve is this sweetness of the heart.
Such a,
uh,
and then he continues.
That's the snow loses its imprint in the sun.
Yeah.
The image of the liquefaction of shapes,
the loss of shapes,
um,
water that had been crystallized just dissolves and then an emerge,
which brings us back to the Aeneid.
The third book,
the Aeneid that's in the wind on the light leaves the symbols.
Oracle was lost.
This is the idea when a,
when an e is,
goes to the Sibos cave to find out about the future,
his future,
and it's the symbol opens the gates,
the wind comes and uh,
and,
and uh,
we'll go on scattering all the leaves kept with it.
And so it's the possibility of reading and in visibility of decipher and,
uh,
the actual live tech sort of messiness and confusion.
That's exactly this.
The state of mind in which he seems to find himself all lights Supreme
Dantanna's shifts to another mode on his own.
And of course,
sequence of prayers,
all light supreme,
they are so far exalted above,
um,
more tokens conceiving grant to my mind,
again,
a little of what our peers and give my tongue.
This is,
this is the kind of the prayer of a,
this is the prayer of,
uh,
that,
language May,
uh,
missing a page here.
So,
um,
uh,
this is the prayer that somehow language now,
may triumph over him over,
over the threats of forgetfulness.
Forgetfulness threatens him.
Why am I insisting so much that it may leave,
but a gleam of the glory to the people yet to come?
Uh,
what Dante is saying is that his poem is meant for the future.
Then in effect,
he's am visioning a future.
This is not a poem written for him.
It's not a poem report written for his contemporaries.
It's a positing of a future is to say the opening up to,
and that's what work we'll do.
A work of art invents and prepares a future.
So more than an act of remembrance and the commemoration that poem will be what
we call it.
I hope it's a prolapses a proleptic move and movement forward into the future.
But why do I talk so much about memory that nothing seems to be becoming now
utopian.
Uh,
lend me some of your glory.
Let me see your glory.
So that spark of it may be left in my text so that the future will understand
that and we'll see.
And some fire can come from that spark.
But why this then language,
this insistence on memory?
Because that's the answer.
He's talks about retrieving the memory of what he has seen.
Because the actual constitution of his poem,
he can only write this poem.
He can only have some authority for his voice
if he remembers what he has seen in order to ground the poem in the,
the notion into the,
the vision of God.
Therefore we'll authorize him to say all the things he has been saying about the
living and the living and the dead,
the powerful,
and then also powerful,
the historical figures and the cultural figures of the past.
It's crucial for him to remember.
So that memory becomes the actual foundation of his representation.
He has to bring it back,
make,
give it a presence to what has gone on in his,
his experience.
And you see what I mean?
So He's forced to go on remembering and yet he cannot.
How is it going?
Well does his authority come from then?
If he can't remember,
and he says he can remember very little,
only the sweetness that has been gathering in the,
in his heart.
Where does it come from?
And this is the third,
fourth challenge of the poem.
I think he continues from the keenest endured of the living
array that I should have been dazzled if my eyes had been turned from it.
And I remember that for this course,
I was the boldest sustain it until I reached with my gaze,
the infinite goodness.
Once again,
breaking the additive and turning into the meditative prayer,
sort of begging,
that's the the divine may reveal itself and remain within or bounding grace but
which are there to fix my local,
the eternal light so long that I spent all my site upon it in its depth.
That's what he sees.
I saw that it contained the cosmos.
I said book,
that's it.
The whole world.
I called it last time at Cosmo book that Cosmos as a book,
I say as a,
as a,
as a parchment maybe,
but he uses also the image of a book which is different from a volume.
The volume is rolled up.
The book is the one which we have a kind of a square structure and the two
together,
uh,
as a kind of allegory wrapped up.
So,
uh,
I think I saw a in its depth,
I saw that it contained,
bound by loves in one volume.
That was the word that had used for Virgil at the beginning of the poem or a way
to give,
continue with it to his,
his quest and his questions begins with the volume of Virgil's book and that the
virtuous book became a,
becomes a prefigure ration of the book of the Cosmos that he sees bound
together,
that which is scattered in leaves through the universe substances and accents
and their relations as it were fused together in such a way that what a tell of
it is a simple light.
I think I saw the universal form of this complex is compound because in telling
of it,
I feel my joy x band.
Now it's the retrieval of or other,
the,
the recovery of this,
this,
this state of mind,
which is one of drawing which doesn't,
which excludes absence.
Desire has to be replaced by Joel builds.
Desire always entails an absence.
We long for what we do not have,
at least at that moment,
right?
Desire is always tied to an experience of lacking.
Joy is a tide is tied to an experience of plenitude of a procession somehow at
this point.
And now another mythological figure that I want to focus on,
um,
a single moment makes for me deeper oblivion.
You see now the,
uh,
the dialectics between memory that fails and the Bolivian does its memory and
efforts that remembering and the reality of forgetfulness.
This is the,
uh,
the,
the dialectic between the two metaphors together.
Uh,
it's single moment makes for me deeper oblivion than five.
Um,
I'll have time,
a single moment when it's with deeper Bolivia,
then five and 20 centuries upon the enterprise that made Neptune wonder at the
shadow of the Argo what an extraordinary hemorrhage,
right?
Single moment.
It's clearly an image to say that I forgot more,
uh,
in one second.
So time doesn't exist here.
It exists in Dante.
Dante still being human.
He still time,
you know,
time is at least he can only,
his life can only be measured by time,
but it's in the presence of the eternal incident.
But a single instance,
these is literally,
I'm just closing this single instance made me forget more than what we have
forgotten in 25 centuries from the experience of the Argo allusion to the
argonauts and our mythological counter to Dante's own journey.
They went for the,
Jason went for the Golden Fleece.
Dante's going for the peer visual.
Another,
another little connection.
The Canto wonder of Paradiso starts with a reference to the story of the
argonauts,
uh,
the daring of the argonauts.
And now Dante is closing the circle here once again,
but there's a further something else then the story of the organoids is done to
retrieves it is that the god is now below.
Neptune is in the depth.
And,
uh,
Dante is now thinking of the divine as being also caught in its hone,
unreachable,
unfathomable depth,
which is a height.
But you see,
there are two different perspectives.
More importantly here,
Dante sees Neptune one very good.
The daring of man just as Neptune is wondering at the varying of the argonauts.
The implication is that he too,
I said this kind of dating,
that the divine,
the God may be wondering at his,
uh,
his own achievement.
What is crucial is the change of perspective from the depth depth of underneath
the sea to the depth.
I'm up in,
uh,
up in the sky,
up in the heavens for a dentist,
God.
And then he continues to pass my mind.
Mine.
Dante's so careful.
I wish we had time about this to show you.
I mean,
I know that there are some graduate students who may want to think about this
whole issue.
How Dante,
Dante's lexicon about mind,
intellect reason is so carefully calibrated and differentiated mind is the
Faculty of Visionary Ness.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's also the,
it's also the root word of measure.
As you know,
Latin etymology is the medieval medieval reminds our,
I always taken with the discovery of the rule words.
It's men's.
There was men may measure,
uh,
comes from the immense,
for instance comes from the word for mind.
It is a fee still keeping a sense of the measure for himself.
He's still aware of his own particular state is not lost in the immensity of
what's around him.
That's my mind.
All wrapped was gazing fixed,
still an intent.
And in kindle with gazing at that light,
when becomes such that it's impossible him ever to consent that it should turn
from it to another site for the good,
which is the object of the will is all gathered in it and apart from it is
defective that will ship which,
which there is perfect.
Now language fails,
memory fails.
The second failure is that of speech.
Now my speech will come more short even or whatever I remember than an infant.
And you know that the word infant,
which usually things take to be um,
the child literally means a child who cannot speak.
You refer,
you use the word infant for someone who is pre,
uh,
were babbling even right.
That's the infant really.
So far,
far in Latin means to speak and infants.
We at Bates his tongue at the breast,
not that the living light,
which I guess had more than a single aspect for it is ever the same as it was
before.
But my site gaining strength is I looked the ones who'll appearance,
I mean I,
myself changing was for me,
transformed in the profound and clear ground of the lofty light appeared to me.
That's the visionary.
He has three circles of three callers and the same,
the same extent.
And the one seemed reflected by the other.
S Rainbow by rainbow in the third seemed fire breeded fourth equally from the
one and the other.
Oh,
how scanned his speech and her feeble to my conception.
It ends with an avoidable statement of failure,
a failure of memory.
So the memory can be forgetful memory and the failure of speech and able to
contain that plenty to do what he sees.
Vision exceeds language,
seeds,
a speech there is more to the text,
Dante saying there's more to my experience of the world then what I can say in
words.
So there is not everything is reducible or containable within the uh,
uh,
the syllable of,
of uh,
of our,
of our language and this to what I saw is that it's enough to call it little or
like a terminal.
Once again they are alone or by this and die self.
A divine that is now are caught within itself and this is self contained.
Look at this in thy self alone knows theirself and known to the self and knowing
lovest and smiles on myself.
This is the kind of inner and closure or circularity of the divine in Italian.
I have to read through the tenant.
So you'll see line one 23,
um oh Lou [inaudible] loan 25,
maybe all Lucita solar intact CD solar thing 10.
The older you understand yourself a that they internet and then the I ami air.
Really see how the words keep repeating it flat falling on themselves to convey
the idea of the self enclosed nature.
Now this is this something that all his escapes,
Huh?
Uh,
our grasp and escapes Dante's grab some,
Eh,
uh,
for all of the diffusive nearness of God in the creation,
there's an element of the divine that literally is absolutely
self-transcendence,
just transcends itself.
A completely that's circling,
which that's big,
appeared in this reflected light.
When my eyes dwelt on it for a time,
seem to meet within it and it's home color painted with our likeness.
That's how he sees.
He sees our own as he calls it,
a fog line.
One 31 nostra a feature our likeness.
It didn't say my likeness.
It's a poor metaphor that at the end seems to one to retrieve the con,
the commonality of the common likeness that we have.
What he sees is the incarnation,
the human image within God.
Because in God,
that is also the human.
Since we are,
if you agree with the principle that we are,
are creations of God,
uh,
and that we were created in his image.
So therefore there's something human also within the divine.
And then he continues like the geometer who sets his mind to the squaring of the
circle,
a famous mathematical served in the Middle Ages,
meaning what of the impossible,
one of the impossible paradoxes of how do you square the circle and the
Geometer's would go on and reflecting on it.
And that's what I'm talking about.
Enterprises himself,
the,
the science of measurement that,
uh,
stumbles against this paradox that the geometer and fails like the geometer who
sets his mind to the squaring of the circle and for his thinking,
there's not discover the principal he needs such will die as a strange sight.
I wish to see how the image was fitted to the circle and how it has its place
there,
but my own wings,
the flight of the soul,
the wings of the soul,
right?
The wings of the soul.
You know,
the platonic idea that we go on developing wings,
you know,
the two arrows,
I'm lousy us to prep,
to unfold a wings for the site was all,
and it's also pun,
I think on a,
uh,
on Dante's owner name.
We've been talking about that we're not sufficient for that had not my mind been
smitten by Flash,
but hidden came.
It's swish here.
Power failed the high fantasy.
Um,
how many fantasies are there?
There are three.
The highest form of the imagination.
That's what he means there.
Eh,
pretty romantic distinction.
I mean Coleridge between imagination and fantasy.
Dante,
uh,
follows up.
Nantais belongs in that same line of thinking.
But now my desire and will like a wheel that spins with even motion would evolve
by the love that moves the sun and the other stars.
And that's the end of the poem.
Uh,
which hands exactly the way,
uh,
with Dante doing two things.
One,
seeing the prime mover and understanding the prime mover,
not the way he did at the beginning of Paradiso.
One but love it wasn't the,
the,
the I,
the definition of God is the prime mover.
You remember simple,
have a limitation for Dante was a prime mover,
moves the universe and somehow then detaches.
This engages himself from it.
Now Dante theses that primal,
the motion is emotion of love.
The Universe is a universe of love but holds the world together and prevents it
from falling apart is exactly this power prevents it from chaos.
It's this power called love.
So the whole of the universe is in motion.
Love that moves the sun and other stars and the only thing stable,
the only thing that makes it go here is,
uh,
is this love by using the same language of love that moves the sun and the other
starts.
Okay.
It's universe of love and the stand that,
yeah,
none.
He uses the,
okay.
See metrically the same.
The same phrase.
The stars moves the sun and the other stars in new fair.
No at the end of the phone or the end of purgatory.
Fair.
Remember that.
And then now I was,
I,
I was so cleanse.
Then off we'll come back and look at the stars,
the handle purgatorio and then now verge or not finally managed to come back and
see the stars.
Non-Thesis says,
ah,
the,
the love that moves the sun and the other stars.
What he's really doing is placing himself immediately with this line right back
on earth.
He's here with us looking up at the stars.
It's the line that shifts,
allows him to shift from the moment of this vision that he has a vision that is
the vision of uh,
of the incarnation.
At the end is we'll say his own our own likeness.
So he sees us all getting members and then comes back to earth.
But it also means that this line places Dante exactly in federal one,
and this is the story of the poem,
this thought of the port.
We have been reading the poem as an account of an experience of a pilgrim who
goes from the dark wood in fair,
no one to the beatific vision,
whatever he remembers of it and then comes back to tell us about it.
What in effect we are also discovering in this reading of the poem is that by
the end of the poem Dante says,
now my journey started,
the real journey was this poem here.
So we are in a sense by that last line caught in the circle of dentist telling
in the drum of Dante's story,
we read the poem,
which is that kind of journey for us.
Then we read because we want to tell our own story and then we want to go on
rereading it.
Uh,
once again,
do you see what I mean?
It's a [inaudible],
uh,
if you wish a witty even a way for Dante to say this poem will hold you,
and it's meant to hold you and I wish it holds you.
Uh,
so you can see the poem is both a journey and the telling of the journey
endlessly like the movement of the sun and they have a sash.
So this is the end of the poem.
Now what,
let me say that I'm sure that they are,
uh,
questions.
I raised some issues that we have minute,
few minutes and uh,
I'll tell you then later,
where are we going to do next time?
So,
ah,
please
outline 52,
um,
that light to blind,
which in itself is true going on here about light and
the light seems to be here.
All right.
What's happening is that Dante is
become,
the faculty improves enough to appreciate that and that has been trying any good
failure now.
But,
um,
how light light is truth,
no longer a lumen.
It is very object at this point.
Okay.
Uh,
the question is,
uh,
in reference to lines 52 line 52 of Paradiso 33,
we are,
uh,
Dante says and die,
who was drawing near to the end level desires.
Okay.
That'd be understand indeed perforce ended perforce the order of my craving.
Say Bernard sign to me with a smile.
Total Cup word,
but already over myself I was doing,
but he wished that's,
I think federally at least literally clear for my sites becoming pure.
Oh,
that
it's also clear they are,
Dante's experience in a final poems are,
can be reduced to every fine meant of,
uh,
and,
and of the Faculty of Vision,
uh,
physical,
but the,
the,
oh,
so clearly spiritual.
Um,
it was,
it was becoming pure,
was entering more and more through the beam of the lofty light,
which in itself is true.
Meaning that I think this means this is also if,
uh,
if the footnote of yours,
it's the,
the footnote is to the famous phrase.
In Thy Light,
we see the light.
Um,
the,
uh,
the idea that we are quite right,
that it's not a light that reveals an object being,
uh,
being a true object.
That's really what you,
the point that you're making.
That's absolutely true.
I would agree with that.
But it's really a statement about the light,
which in itself is a contains highlight.
Is it,
it's kind of a,
that's the meaning of the biblical phrase.
In Thy Light,
we see the light.
It's not because of your light.
I see the world,
I see myself or whatever.
Uh,
you know,
in their light,
I see the light.
The light is,
uh,
is the light of truth.
That's what he saying.
It's a light of truth in and of itself.
That of truth.
Yes,
it's a light in itself.
But that was your point or,
no,
just a little confused.
That was a function of where the function of light,
uh,
here.
Um,
well the,
I can,
I can give you a little bit of,
uh,
the idea of what we call the metaphysics of light in,
in,
uh,
in Paradiso.
Okay.
Uh,
Dante begins with the idea that,
uh,
what do we know of the divine is,
is light.
Okay.
I light that,
uh,
the power of which I sent it to,
the limitation of which is exactly like the doc in the sense that their light
reveals to us the divine,
but at the same time hides the origin of the lights.
You can not see through the light.
Okay.
That's really the understanding of a downtime parodies or one saying the glory
of him.
Who else move soul things?
The glory is an image really means slide.
That I have a claim who moves on things is what I really saw.
Now Dunphy seeing the origin of that,
that light,
uh,
that which has remained forever invisible.
Exactly the way the dog,
you might say that,
you know,
some of our imagination,
uh,
is that we are in the dark.
We don't know what the origins of anything.
We don't know the causes that lie beyond,
uh,
perceptions,
right?
Um,
but we don't know the origin of the dark.
And we may even go like mystics believing that the dark is the image is the
cover for light.
You know what?
If they said dark,
they must be a light somewhere else.
In fact,
that dog may occasionally be removed.
The worst thing about the mystical language of the divine in terms of right is
that the right itself,
which makes all things visible,
remains in and of itself impenetrable in its origin to the human eye.
Now Dante sees it.
That's the idea of the truth,
right?
In daylight,
we see the light.
Okay?
Is that a little,
this is not a beatific vision.
He has seen a moment of light and the origin of the light.
That's still not God,
but at the beatific,
the old,
the only thing that he remembers,
the beatific vision is some,
he doesn't say some sweetness that has gathered in his heart.
And what he then sees beyond the general forms,
this is a number of things,
the general form of the cosmos,
which is this conjunction of circle and square a book and volume.
You know,
if you want to visualize it in terms of,
and I,
I like that image because it really implies that the word,
ah,
that's,
that's the,
it's the theology of the word that seems to come out of that.
Then the other thing that he sees is our likeness.
I,
he,
he sends us back to genesis one or the creation of man and is told in Genesis,
uh,
let us make,
let us make
man in our image and likeness.
So this is our likeness.
But you are talking now about the light and the meaning about this light.
Is that the light,
what does it mean to say that the light is true?
Not because he reveals and dissipates the shadows.
That would be one way,
one functions of the light.
We liked the light,
the light of the mind to like the sun,
whatever,
because of that,
the artificial lights.
But there is a way in which Dante's now thinking about what,
what is called metaphysics of light.
What is the light in and of itself and the light and not,
by the way,
if you really want to know this,
Dante distinguishes between the word for light and the word for lamp,
Lou Lou tray,
and so on,
light a lamp and so on.
And number of,
uh,
scientific distinctions.
But here he's talking about the vision of the origin of light.
In very light,
we see the light.
That's the meaning of the phrase.